and what i'm gonna do in this class guys
uh i will be bringing
uh positions
uh example positions from a real games
and asking you to find the moves okay so
i'll tell you who is playing this game
and see if you can find the solution
okay
so let's start out with the first outer
first position here we have this
position
all right so i'll set this up for you so
white
to play and win here this one
okay
white to play and win here
can you find this is a uh grandmaster
gundaman is playing
against gramase lalit from india
why to play and win
why to play and win so what do you think
is the idea here guys
all right let's see if
please put your answers in the chat guys
put your answers in a chat
makes it easy to okay the perfect
fantasy contest okay well that's just
the one move guys
that's just the one move i need i need
i need more than just one move okay
i need the whole validation from your
chest players
okay knight g7 is good but what is black
going to do
okay
so take you have to take and you also
have to look at this move too
okay so first things first if it takes
where is the wind
first things first so we take
now if he goes here we have mate say
goes here
what do you do
g60 i like this six yeah
now queen g7 mate and if it takes
now i go queen g7 and queen g8 mate
yeah now just queen g8 mate
yep
all right so what if he does this guys
cringy for now what do you do
look d1 is hanging j7 is hanging
so it's a problem
yeah correct aryan correct aryan
yes rook d3 now if it takes you have
rook g7 okay
if it takes anywhere we have rooked
yourself so it has to go here
and now what is the idea here
now what to do
now what is the correct move here nope
it's not queen f6 queen f6 here's rookie
one check you get made it
queen f6 you get made it
rook g3 here is a queen d1 check
now knight e6 perfect knight e6 okay
there's no need to do anything else
knight e6 now you have this monstrous
idea here
rook g3 and now he cannot go anywhere
okay
it's amazing that king cannot go
anywhere if he goes to h8 you go queen
f6
check and then rook g2 so it's very
tricky
okay what to do
now g3 is coming up in just just a tough
position he cannot do anything guys to
defend this
okay game is over and that's how gundam
beat lalit bob lalit grand master lalit
babut
in the asian continental championship
all right okay so again knight takes g7
exposing opponent's king if takes queen
f6 is a mate
so he has to go something like this and
then simply nice
oh sorry t3 threatening group g3
and 96 with idea rook g3 winning the
game
perfect
okay i'm gonna get to the next good job
guys we're gonna do the next position
now okay
all right let's see this one here
open up the board
okay
okay why to play
white to play and win here this is a
game between grand master
almashi white against bruzon
white to play and win
what to do in this tricky position here
what to do to try to win this game
well he actually didn't find it almashi
didn't find it
almashi played here and now a very
strong move by brook zone
after which the game was equal okay
so after c5 he allowed the equalization
here
but there was a very strong idea here
you could try to do here
please don't rush guys think a little
bit
so what's the idea here we have to do
something here
g4 no it's not g4 it's not
c5 what is c5 no we can't play c5
c5 very suspicious c5 for who c4
not good enough how are you winning the
exchange steiner steiner how do you win
exchange
take
well we can't uh play queen f3 right
away because he'll take our knight
okay so for on then okay
ah this is what you want to do okay
yeah now you're turning this yeah that's
correct
that's correct yes
rugby two you have knight c6 so he has
to take
and now what is the important idea
you're going to do here
oh thank you thank you a gaming how you
doing thank you
and now always remember when you see a
good move when you think you can win
something always try to see
if maybe you can win something even
bigger than that okay
97 correct yaroslav correct the arrow
sloth
and then you take that guy absolutely
absolutely correct us
yeah absolutely okay all right
very good guys that was excellent that
was excellent
we are going to continue now with this
positions
this is a silent move topic okay
this particular is a silent move and i
mean this is
this is a really silent move you're
sacrificing a pawn and then you're
playing a deadly move queen f3
i mean that's really a silent silencing
the opponent okay
all right white to play and win
since you know the theme now it's a
little bit easier for you now
what to do
okay white to play
and win guys and you have to play like a
young
belgium grandmaster's spallman
spallman and he was playing against a
grandmaster from netherlands
uh actually spawned maybe from the the
netherlands too
against ernst white
to play and win
yeah this looks really dangerous for
black i agree with you but you still
have to manage to
to win this position
okay fight to play and win guys
what you gonna do here
silent move is the team
wow
wow this is a really a tricky position
okay
yeah very very very tricky
you know black probably thought he might
actually even win this game because it
looks like
there is nothing going on immediately
and black has
enough control with this and trading
queens he probably thought he has enough
going here
to maybe even win it
it's like you need one more piece on a h
file you know
you need one more piece to on a h file
that's what you really that's your
missing link you know
one more piece on a file
f5 you know f5 is a little too slow here
okay queen g1 no queen g1
i take
queen take screen okay
yeah but i have don't i have f6 here
yeah if i go back here okay chase me but
i have a six
yeah if you take
i take
yeah bishop f6 he has king of six
okay bishop before but aren't you like
down exchange here
yeah i think you're just down exchange
all right guys uh we need to keep more
uh control
it's a queen move queen e1 okay that's
correct when you want now you're
threatening queen h4
queen interest so he has to take
now what do you do
okay but now now what you're gonna do
you have a good follow-up here
yeah normally it's not good i agree but
here you have a follow-up
rook g7
it goes here
now what to do
if you take on b4 i go queen to e4
that's what i would like to do
now we have to get our no it's not queen
h4 it's not good
he's gonna play
yeah rook g8
now what's the idea here
now if he goes here
uh
now he has this
now you have queen d3 check to actually
take
all right so let's go back and try to
find a better move here okay
now what's the special move here you
have a special move here
you need to get your bishop involved
okay
guys bishop c4 beautiful wonderful
now if he goes here who can show me the
finish here
now let's see what you do here
yeah correct
correct atulia
rook h8 here i think uh you just take
yeah
check
can go to f7 can't go anywhere up
if you go back look take stroke
and just expose the position in queen
all right
all right next position
good job so that's the that's the idea
guys queen e1 and then you just have a
very powerful attack okay next one
okay white to play and win okay
white to play and win guys
okay
white to plane when
so what do you think is the quiet move
idea how is the quiet move idea
going to work now 36.
oh oh okay
yeah we can play knight g5 g4 g5
now how can white try to win this
position here guys let's see here
bishop g6 okay
well i'm not talking about the first
move later on you have to make a quiet
move
okay later on you play you make a quiet
move guys
um what else what else you can do
now first we start out with a check
now it's going to take check he's going
to go here
then what do we do
now we're gonna get the knight into the
game
now we want to bring the knight into the
game
knight f4
now he goes queen d7
and now you go here anything
yeah he cannot defend this position
after you play knight f4
just a quiet move bringing it to h5 it's
just going to be a mate
on g7 okay
if it takes you knight h5 we have queen
g7 made
okay
all right very good guys so
f5 defender rook what about f5 in which
position f5
here oh okay hitting the coin
mate okay
right away wow
oh yeah now this this is just
i think just knight f4 knight g6
i mean this this just looks bad
this just looks bad uh
yeah i know you might thinking about
this but i think
check check check
has to go here and here attack the queen
attacked yourself
yeah there's mate don't you sound all
right very good
next position guys
good work good work everybody
i need you to play like an ishtiri here
a niche giddy okay
white to play and win okay
why to plan when i need you to play like
anish kitty and you need to defeat
alex say shirov okay you want to try to
defeat
alex's shirov here guys how you gonna do
that
white to play
all right so what are we doing here i
need you to play like a niche
how are you gonna play like a niche here
huh how are you going to play quietly
and win this game
guys i need a whole line you're just
giving me one more okay i don't need
one move i need the whole line okay
you
um
um
now what to do here
um
now what to do
so what did anish play here
all right what is the idea here knight
h4
okay now he takes
now if you take he's gonna take here so
it's not gonna work
okay
now when he takes here what kind of move
you can do
and now you have to try to do what
rook g8 first yes inserting group g8
and you take this okay perfect guys
great work okay
and at the end we're gonna do one
difficult study are you ready
are you ready for a difficult study okay
guys
white
all right
all right let's try to do this one here
but i want to complete answers guys i
don't want
just one or two moves okay i want
complete answers
okay
yeah this is casparian yeah this is
casparian brain
melters this is by
no this is yeah it's from the casparian
book
okay white to play
and draw
why to play and draw
so what do we do here the knight is
trapped it looks like we are kaput you
know
it looks like we are kaput no i know
that's that's easy yaroslav
that is a yellow slab but what's the
idea
you have to find the best moves for for
for for white as well
okay
so the first one is very important we
have to try to get the
a pawn rolling so we can play a5 and
knight b6 okay
the problem if you go here
he goes here sorry
he goes here
that's here now if you move the knight
if you move the king
he goes here now yes this
uh yeah so it's tricky
take picture he has this still okay
here
so what's the important move here
so what do we do here what what what
critical move we have to make here guys
what critical move we have to make king
e2 okay
hitting the bishop
so he has to move the bishop somewhere
let's say he goes here
what do you do what do you accomplish
what do you accomplish by doing this
okay
now we go here
if he goes here you go here he goes here
you got this
okay so it goes here
now we go knight c7 perfect he
you know now he has to take perfect
now we go here now he goes here it looks
like wait a minute
it's not happening he's defending it
what's not happening what are you gonna
do though
yeah now the bishop moves you just take
the pawn
he goes here it's still made perfect
all right very good very very good guys
and if you play k2 what if i go here
yeah if i go here it's again you have to
make sure i cannot defend it from here
okay that's the whole point so that's
the whole point you don't want to give
my bishop an access
here you're going to get me with a tempo
so here
you're going to give me with the tempo
like you're gonna get this position but
now you have an escape move here
what's the move here guys
yeah absolutely knight c7
and now if it takes you take all right
guys
thank you very much for watching guys
and uh
this will be my last uh video for this
for the grand master in residence for
the chess club
i'll i'll continue my streaming on
twitch
at my twitch gm varacobian you've
probably seen it
so make sure you stop by and follow that
and also i'll be starting to
upload more materials on my youtube
channel gm varacobian
so looking forward to seeing you soon
and i'm sure i'll be back again for the
more lectures for the century chess club
guys so
thank you very much guys yeah gm
varacobian guys make sure you follow me
gm varacobian on twitch okay
so i've been doing a lot of twitching
okay so
sounds good thank you guys thank you
everybody and
looking forward to seeing you uh on
twitch okay
very soon this weekend okay all right
thanks guys
excellent job everybody is a strong
strong
group today we had strong players who
managed to tackle these difficult
positions okay
so you guys did awesome okay great work
everybody
and i'll see you very soon on twitch
okay
take care guys have a great evening bye